tonight on the new reality yes this was
predictable the unseen crisis ghovat 19
is hitting communities that are socially
and economically marginalized or
disadvantaged hardest tale of the test
we work behind the scenes to provide
results that the doctors need people
were clapping calling in the troops this
situation is so dire people need help a
curtain call for theatres there have
been plagues there have been viruses
that have been pandemics and it's always
come back and the zoo reality we need to
make sure that we're not just leaving
those animals without support
[Music]
hello I'm Donna freezin
it feels like our future rests on tests
right now test to see who is positive
for Kovac 19 tests to see who has
antibodies to Kovac 19 and might be
immune
no country knows the true picture of the
spread of this virus because no country
has tested everyone here in Canada
almost a million and a half Canadians
have been tested for koban 19 so far
that's less than 4% of the population
the more you test the easier it becomes
to track the spread of the virus and
reduce transmission that's especially
important as we start to open up the
economy and get people back to work
tonight Jeff's simple dissects the
intricate anatomy of a Koba 19 test this
has become the new focal point in the
fight against Cova at 19
these aren't frontline doctors or nurses
instead they're laboratory technologists
and technicians and these days they have
their hands everyone is trying to wrap
up with the testing abilities Humber
River Hospital is home to one of
Ontario's 26 labs tasked with testing
handling potentially hazardous samples
to determine whether a patient is
infected with kovat 19 we work behind
the scenes to provide results that the
doctors need and those results are now
needed badly as businesses reopen and
restrictions are lifted knowing who is
and isn't sick could mean the difference
between preventing a second wave of the
virus testing is key to understanding
when new cases arise that we can descend
upon them with overwhelming force and
suppress those handful of cases from
becoming an outbreak from the start the
priority has been testing frontline care
workers like 35 year-old Lajoie the
mother of four works in a care home for
people with disabilities and last month
she suddenly lost her sense of smell my
mother-in-law was frying fish one day
and you know how fish smells I couldn't
smell it and I was like why can't I
smell it and then when I was trying to
eat I couldn't taste it and I know I
didn't have a cold at that point and it
lasted a long time so that's when I knew
that something was clearly wrong any
symptoms at all
so Lajoie came to this Assessment Center
to be tested for Co vid 19 the test
itself is pretty simple
a quick albeit uncomfortable swab of the
throat or the sinuses you have to open
right and see the whole process is over
in less than 30 seconds but the sample
placed in this test tube still has a
long way to go
only high-risk patients the very sick
requiring surgery will have their tests
processed here
the rest are labeled placed in a cooler
bag and picked up by a courier then
driven to different labs across Toronto
where they joined the queue not all lots
have the capacity to process large
volumes of of samples that might
influence the delay on results and
capacity remains a concern when test
results arrive at the Humber River
Hospital lab they're taken to a separate
area through three sets of protective
doors and negative pressure rooms first
staff put on their protective gear then
carefully move the nasal swab from the
test tube into one of these cartridges
before placing it into this specialized
machine which analyzes the DNA for two
genes connected to kovat 19 it doesn't
take long this is the m2 gene and this
is the e gene so specifically it's
detected and it's giving a result of a
positive result it takes less than an
hour to reveal the patient is positive
but this is the labs only machine from
an American manufacturer and it can only
process 16 tests at a time and the tests
themselves are in short supply prior to
this year there was nobody developing
that test so every company that's now
developing that test has had to ramp up
production their supply chain issues and
there's huge demand for the tests it's
as simple as that the result this
high-tech lab which conducts more than
10,000 tests for other diseases each
week can only process around 200 weekly
tests for kovat 19 I do wish that we had
more testing capability so that we could
be more informed with our
decision-making we're gonna ramp up this
testing like this problems has never
seen Ontario and Quebec the provinces
hardest hit by the pandemic are also
having the toughest time with testing no
you don't need it at this Quebec care
home worker lied about having symptoms
so she could receive a test and her
result came back positive
I couldn't believe the fact that I had
to fight and lie to get a test her story
underscores the importance of testing
because many cases are mild or even
symptom free we need to do surveillance
testing we need to try and get a measure
of that portion of the iceberg that's
under the water
those asymptomatic cases we need to do
that before we open alberta is now doing
just that
testing residents in Calgary and Brooks
regardless of symptoms the criteria for
testing which is key they have allowed a
greater number of laboratories to
participate in the testing process for a
while in Ontario for example only the
Public Health labs were engaged in the
testing capacity but we needed to loosen
up those criteria to commercial labs
University labs it's all hands on deck
scenario after three days of waiting
l'homme ease test result came back
positive I was scared to be honest with
you because I have my mother-in-law I
have my children that was back on April
14th after a couple of weeks her
symptoms disappeared and she went back
for a second test but those results came
back positive again all they told me is
that now that I already finished my two
weeks isolation and I have no symptoms
whatsoever that I couldn't go out in the
community but make sure that we do
social distancing you can't blow this
one she's now been tested five times all
of them positive fortunately her husband
tested negative and her children never
developed symptoms I'm just waiting for
that negative so I can really get back
to work the molecular test is so
sensitive that it can pick up viral
genetic material even in the absence of
somebody being sick and the hospital lab
director says they're about to add a new
test serologic a made in italy blood
test just approved by Health Canada that
checks a patient for antibodies that
tells you how many people have have been
exposed and have hopefully partial or
complete immunity versus people who
haven't been exposed and it helps you
more with public policy decision making
this lab plans to start conducting
logic antibody tests by the end of the
month the better the testing the greater
our understanding of a virus that in
many ways remains a mystery
the virus is a mystery that's making
lives a misery even before we'd ever
heard of Koba 19 there were people
living on the edge in this country more
than three million Canadians live below
the poverty line and about 4 million
have inadequate access to food now
they're slipping further Allyson bouche
NIC reports on the vulnerable who live
on the margins of society and need help
now more than ever
[Music]
here the pandemic cuts through exposing
the cracks the inequities that have long
existed
the borough of Montreal North is one of
the most devastated areas in the country
the Cova 19 infection rate is close to
double the average we can see that
ghovat 19 is hitting communities that
are socially and economically
marginalized or disadvantaged hardest
among those who already live in
difficult situations with lower incomes
many are also frontline health and
essential workers all that contributed
to the spread
they're working in occupations that
already paid very little but now have
been deemed essential right and because
of that because they already didn't have
savings and they have families to
support they have to go to work to put
food on the table
living in multi-generational racially
and ethnically diverse and high-density
settings people start to realize that
the disproportionate impact that kovat
19 has on certain population groups
while Canadians were told to stay inside
many of the most disadvantaged had
little choice I think about people that
don't have access to a car for example
so they have to take public transit so
they might just have to be in settings
where they are with mixing with other
populations at a greater frequency and
that's going to increased risk of
infection
[Music]
these critical issues are called the
social determinants of health social and
economic factors like income
discrimination access to quality food
health care and education all of it
impacts a person's health and how long
they will live also these are groups
that generally have already suffered
long-standing health inequalities so
they're more likely to be sick already
so it's really a variety of factors that
lead to them being much more vulnerable
to both getting code vid 19 and
suffering really terrible consequences
those who study Public Health say this
was predictable the inequities existed
before the pandemic hit and a
communities across the country once the
infection became more community spread
we saw these gradients across
socio-economic size that have a widened
over the course of the pandemic it's not
just about who gets infected the
pandemic is also impacting those in less
secure and low paying jobs statistics
Canada says they have suffered greater
job losses
in the shadows they are suffering the
most vulnerable struggling before the
pandemic now even worse
it's almost impossible to have good
health without stable housing the
shelter system already under-resourced
scrambling to cope with physical
distancing and caring for this at-risk
group the virus claiming lives it's just
such a difficult situation any
congregate living situation this virus
has proven to be extremely contagious
and spread very easily and there are
others struggling many of those with
disabilities are suffering with programs
canceled and services reduced and so
many seniors are isolated at home to
understand how great the need is you
need to go to the agencies and charities
that are supporting the vulnerable it's
been tough for them as well donations
dropping physical distancing and the
need rising and the numbers like the
numbers have increased exponentially the
people that were in the lineups before
kovat aren't still there and now there's
twice as many
Second Harvest is Canada's largest food
rescue it is in the intersection of two
problems a food system with too much
wasted food and too many people going
hungry one kovat nineteen hit it really
magnified the existing problem and then
it created an even larger scale
challenge both with the amount of food
that is going into landfill and the
amount of people that really need to
access his food
that's where food rescue za comes in if
someone has food to donate anywhere in
the country they are connected with the
charity in their local community who
needs it over sixty thousand
organizations in Canada 60,000 use food
in their program charities and
nonprofits so we need to map those
charities with the 58 percent of surplus
and lost food to make sure that it goes
through the system and so we do that
with a matchmaking system that I refer
to as the eHarmony of food because it's
really simple
since the pandemic started the website
ramped up in March it has helped to
rescue close to seven million pounds of
food and help thousands of charities
when the Second Harvest trucks roll out
the head to charities like the East
Scarborough Boys and Girls Club these
halls usually loud and lively now quiet
the programs and center is a lifeline
for so many from children to seniors
with its multiple programs it helps
close to six thousand children and youth
every year it's unprecedented
now the help is coming in a new form the
club is receiving additional food from
Second Harvest than packaging hampers
it's gonna challenge but an opportunity
I think across the sector and for us
locally to look at how we can scale up
our services to make sure we are not
letting anyone fall between the gaps
twice a week staff members are
personally taking the food to families
who need it so far delivering more than
5,000 hampers
dami lola is trying to keep her
seven-year-old busy and safe as a single
mother she's still working from home but
her hours have been cut back paying for
rent and food and all the bills is no
longer possible things that's a worry
about okay your finances what's going to
happen your credit card what are we
going to do about that and then your
rent go thank ya so for the first time
she's receiving food hampers twice a
week did to help every week so that's a
that's a very good initiative and we're
grateful she's grateful and this works
for now but if her rent returns to a
full amount and her income is still
reduced she could get into trouble fast
if I was paying my full rent and wishes
there's no way I came in so because
they're more bills to pay and then the
income is not enough at this time back
at the Boys and Girls Club they know
people are anxious and need more help
they are now offering education supports
and virtual activities we've started to
do analysis across the community through
our assessments and the reality is that
looking at the metrics it may take
almost a year of these continued
emergency-type supports to support
families so that they can balance out
and resume some type of normalcy and
that raises a critical part of the
social and economic factors of health
data to see who is being impacted and
how best to help but the collection of
this information in Canada has been
inconsistent at best when we are missing
data on segments of the population that
are at risk it really hinders our
ability to make sure that our responses
are protecting those people or in worst
case scenario not making the situation
more risky for certain groups in the
population
it also means we need to be better
prepared for targeting help before the
second wave of infection
starts the one thing about Infectious
Diseases is that that we neglect groups
of the population that means that the
outbreak will continue either any point
in time to understand that anyone being
affected means everyone could be
affected that challenge could also
present an opportunity in place of
staying reopening we say reimagining I
think one of the ways we need to
reimagine our society is in a way that
will reduce the deleterious impact of
these social determinants of health
almost every single health problem you
can think of really breaks down along
socio-economic gradients and the most
vulnerable people always bear the worst
brunt to these health problems this
might be a sort of small window and we
can reimagine society to break that
cycle there's lots of help needed lots
of things to fix with me is dr. Andrew
Bhusari he's executive director of
Health and Social Policy at Toronto's
University Health Network dr. at the
start of this pandemic the virus was
referred to as the great equalizer
that's not really true is it no no Donna
the more more we're learning the more
and more we're seeing there is nothing
equalizing about kovat it is really a
cruel exposure of long-standing
inequality and poverty you know we're
seeing this concentrate with the data
we're hearing this with the stories but
really none of this is surprising but
that's also what's compounding the
crisis and what's making it even more
worrisome for people who aren't on the
frontlines like you are can you explain
how the lack of safe housing and poverty
intersect to put people at greater risk
of getting coded 19-hole vyd has you
know torn back the curtain on any sort
of way to ignore this of any sort of
weight not to see the connection if an
individual is experiencing homelessness
they do not have places to physically
isolate they are constantly at risk they
are constantly in situations where
they're not able to also have any usual
or what we would hope for health care
delivery or in health care access and
then I think the other challenge on this
has also been
it's for the under house right as well
that we're seeing these issues of where
physical distancing is a privilege it
has not been afforded to all and what
we're seeing it come up with covet is
that it's really coming at the cost and
the expense of the poor there needs to
be an opportunity for individuals to
have the human dignity and the
protection that we would expect and
demand for everybody living in Canada
has not played out so I think you know
from you know again there is incredible
heroism by the individuals who are
experiencing this every hour of the day
who have had to look out for family
members for themselves there is
incredible courage by the frontline
shelter staff by community workers who
are in shelters who are in the
facilities to do all that they can to
help individuals from our health care
workers and hospitals but really what
we're seeing is that this is not a fault
of any individual these are not faults
of any collection of individuals but
these are structural issues insist
system level elements that have now been
exposed that have been I would argue
exposed for a long time but are now
really unannounced more at risk as that
happens are they more at risk as we
start to open up or have some supports
been put in place for them or there are
their safe places for example for them
to quarantine or recover if they've been
sick you know I think that the reopening
comes with really serious risks for
those who are already most disadvantaged
we've seen this from from data where
it's individuals again or at the
frontline but are individuals who we've
called you know essential workers now
but for a long time we also had no issue
calling unskilled or minimum wage but
they have had maximal courage in doing
what they need to do to allow whatever
parts of the economy have stayed open
whatever parts of services have stayed
open have really been through the
courage and dedication of these workers
who have deemed essential and I hope
that we also continue in that same
respect in that same view of the things
that they need to happen and really I
just think it's about individuals being
able to have the confidence and trust in
the system as things
the economy will never come back to life
if there's no confidence and I think
that the other piece of this is we will
never see the health outcomes we want if
there's not trust in the system that
people are not going to be overlooked
that people are not going to be
neglected and people are not going to be
you know essentially sacrificed for
certain parts of the economy to restart
while individuals again have been under
chronic neglect and now it's not hard to
connect the dots as to the risks that
they're under do you think that we're
opening up the economy too quickly those
who are most at risk of this with the
opening of their economy are racialized
marginalized populations we've seen this
with personal support workers again
where this has long been known that it's
usually racialized women in these
situations who've been under a
precarious employment not having the
control and autonomy that we would hope
for everyone working in our health care
system they've had to have you know this
courage and this dedication for years
and again kovat has blown the top off
any of these issues of where people have
been in precarious work where people
have been in unsafe work conditions and
so again when the economy reopens it's
those individuals who will be at the
forefront
it's those individuals who will face the
consequences and I think again we have
to go back to decide what do we owe each
other what elements at what levels of
protection need to be in place before we
can safely reopen
still ahead I wanna see the Lions the
bison the grizzly bears drive-thru zoo
plan that allows people to stay in their
vehicles get a behind-the-scenes unique
experience the new reality of a trip to
see the animals plus performing post
pandemic I'm looking forward to the
future when we can have human
connections again the reality of getting
Canadian artists back on the stage and
troops facing an invisible enemy it's a
lot of work but it's a good work that
we're doing canada's armed forces
pitching in where it's needed most
[Music]
for those with loved ones in long-term
care the weight has been agonizing for
more than ten weeks they've been unable
to visit in person unable to hug or even
hold the hand of the person they love
staying away is supposed to stop the
spread of kovat 19:00 but we know it has
already spread like wildfire in hundreds
of homes it's so bad the military has
been called in no one ever thought
soldiers would be looking after seniors
yet there they are
fourteen hundred troops deployed in 25
long-term care homes in Quebec and 275
working in five facilities in Ontario
how did it come to this Mike Armstrong
takes us through it even before there
was a request for help the Canadian
Armed Forces were preparing planning for
what might come in a normal spring it's
usually flooding or forest fires but by
this meeting April 6th there was also
the increasing likelihood troops would
be needed in a fight against kovat 19
the coronavirus was already sweeping
through seniors residences in Quebec and
Ontario the death toll was rising what
it was also doing was exposing the
fragility of the system even before
kovat nineteen quebec's long term care
facilities were already struggling with
staffing this took them past the
breaking point
some residents has lost more than half
their staff to infection to preventive
leave or even out of fear a desperate
Premier called on anyone in the
healthcare system to help out we need
you to do the basic work I appeal to
your sense of duty to help us take care
of the elderly those appeals went out
daily and didn't work there were more
and more stories about overworked staff
being overwhelmed Canadian doctors who
volunteer in other countries on
humanitarian missions were told by
quebec's health minister to stay home
what I'm saying is that this year now I
think the humanitarian mission is here
in Quebec in our long-term facilities
the first call to the military for help
was April 15th it was a Wednesday by the
Saturday troops read on recce visiting
residences to see what was needed and
where they were very welcome people were
clapping listen this situation is so
dire that people need help
by that Monday April 20th about 65
troops moved into five Quebec residences
that first phase was soldiers with
medical backgrounds physicians nurses
orderlies and they were able to jump
right into the action all we barely got
in and we were already working knees
even if we were we were put to work as
fast as I could now despite that initial
response staffing shortages turned into
a full-blown crisis there were cases
where residences saw their entire staff
not show up for work it reached the
point where kovat 19 wasn't the only
thing sending seniors to hospital
it was also inadequate care there were
cases of dehydration and malnutrition
April 22nd the premier put out another
call the station and senior residences
is still critical
today we've hashed the federal
government to send a thousand soldier
the second wave of soldiers was more
complicated to deploy they needed
training and how to use protective gear
and some of the basics and how to care
for seniors the tasks were similar to
what an orderly might do and very
different from what most troops signed
up for once on the ground they knew they
were needed it's a lot of work but it's
a good work that we're doing it's a
we're taking a lot of the stress out of
the civilian employees that are working
there full-time the troops have been
called extra arms even if they don't
have the medical background staff would
normally have they're helping how much
when we put that question to this nurse
recently she answered with exasperation
I can't point I can't point no Cyndi
hubby show says the soldiers have let
her and the rest of the staff breathe
and made them feel supported
she also said they're already nervous
about what happens the soldiers leave
operation laser is the name of Canada's
military response to this pandemic and
colonel tim arsenault is the commander
of it in long-term care homes in the
montreal area he's leading the teams of
reservists and Regular Force members who
are not only from Quebec but from all
over Canada colonel arsenal thank you so
much for joining us you served in Bosnia
and in Afghanistan and in Ukraine you're
an infantry officer now you're helping
in a war against a virus inside Care
Homes in Canada this isn't what anyone
in the military signed up for what's
been the greatest challenge it is a
significant challenge to operate in a
pandemic environment especially at home
I think a year ago none of us would have
expected that we'd be involved in a
mission of this nature however you know
that our business is adapting to
challenging environments and our
soldiers have definitely shown that that
we're very capable of adapting to this
one as well give me a sense of the
logistics we know that one of the main
reasons care homes are so badly infected
with koban 19 is because staff prior to
this we're moving from care home to care
home and working in multiple facilities
so how are you ensuring that there isn't
the kind of cross infection and that you
know enough care is taken that that both
your soldiers and people inside those
care homes are not going to get covert
19 as you know we're used to deploying
and large numbers occupying caps large
groups of soldiers living together
traveling together working together this
situation is very different and that we
need to make sure that we don't become
vectors of the virus within the the
homes I've you've as you've pointed out
that entails a lot of changes in terms
of transportation feeding plans bet down
in terms of you know having each soldier
needs to have their own room with their
own with their own their own washroom to
ensure that that we don't pass it off to
each other and then then again into the
homes and in terms of you know the
cross-pollination between centers
we're applying the same rules as as the
ministry is so our teams in general
terms are not moving from one facility
to the next and those specific medical
teams that are more of a limited
resource when we do need to to move them
it's done in accordance with provincial
regulations in that regard how many
soldiers have tested positive for kovat
19 and have any become seriously ill I'm
not at liberty to speak of the specifics
of the numbers as they are today or I
can't tell you that the numbers will
increase the numbers are very small
given the number of troops that we have
working in long-term care facilities
everyone very much appreciates
everything that you're doing but as the
prime minister said soldiers really
shouldn't be taking care of seniors his
operational laser kind of an indefinite
operation at this point you'll note that
since since the end of April we we
initially provided support to five
long-term care facilities we sharply
increased that over the course of the
first few weeks have made 225 centres
within the Montreal region again over a
thousand soldiers directly involved in
the long-term care facilities we have
around 1,400 soldiers in the Montreal
region tat in total including the
logistics and and in command and control
elements so we're here to provide that
assistance for as long as the government
asks us to do so
coming up bringing down the curtain
there's something that happens when
there's a screen between the audience
and the human who's performing setting
the stage for post koban performances
[Music]
many of us have been binge watching
shows and movies from the comfort and
safety of our couch and all those things
we used to do together theater concerts
comedy clubs they're a distant memory
the idea of being packed into a place
with hundreds of other people is still
largely unthinkable well some countries
are starting to reopen their movie
theaters we still don't have a release
date to return to Canadian cinemas and
traditional theater isn't expected to
raise its curtain to the public until
sometime in 2021 artists musicians and
actors are all struggling and as Robin
Gill explains they're coming up with new
ways to get creative the neon lights on
Broadway are far from bright they're not
even on
[Music]
but chelina Kennedy isn't deterred the
Canadian actor and musician had the
starring role in the musical about
Carole King's life when kovat brought
down the curtain in New York Kennedy was
in rehearsals and fittings for a new
production she made a run for the border
and these days like everyone else
she's hunkered down at home in Ontario
the lights will come back on she insists
but with no idea when I think we will go
back to traditional theater and I think
we must go back to traditional theater
because there is a name for virtual
theater and it's called film and
television and I think that we can't
replace you know there's a there's
something that happens when there's a
screen between the audience and the
human who's performing the social
distancing festival is hoping to fill
the void for the productions that have
been disrupted or delayed it's a
platform that offers a way for creative
types from around the world to
collaborate whether it's dance art or
music I think it's sort of important for
all artists to figure out ways to
translate their work to digital means
just to have a broader reach Nick green
a Canadian playwright is the brains
behind the festival he sees himself as
an artist matchmaker and wonders if this
could be the future of the Arts
there were a lot of efforts being made
to figure out how to translate the arts
to digital means there were already
grant programs and a lot of industry
leaders trying to look at that question
I think this has expedited that question
a huge amount and live from zoom it's
sometime between March and August
life in the time of Cova is forcing
actors to get creative in the zoom room
take Saturday night not so live the
skits and improv have a flat feel how
much you what you work on no I don't
believe that will be the norm people are
looking to get back in the studio and
and it's it's a little bit limiting in
terms of what you can do without any
interaction
Jennifer McCarran is the CEO of
Thunderbird entertainment the Canadian
production company behind Blade Runner
20:49 they know you're here she says
Hollywood we'll get rolling soon movies
and TV shows have been shot there just
waiting to be produced both for the
theatres and streaming services contents
a business that does well in times of
recession it's an escape Netflix
set the standard and now we have Disney
and Apple and Hulu and all of those
aren't startup companies and they're
coming online into streaming because
it's such a hugely successful business
and now people can watch content anytime
on any device anywhere in a hundred and
ninety countries you know 40 different
languages the reach that that has is
tremendous this independent cinema in
Vancouver has been showing films since
1935 the auditorium isn't a full house
anymore
moviegoers will have to respect social
distancing rules so seats have been
taken out reduced from forty rows to
just twenty and the types of movies will
be geared to a certain demographic as we
open up we're in a cater to those people
that are are younger for sure that I
don't have the same degree of fear young
male films are arguing to do better than
a young female films males tend to not
have the same degree of fear that
females do in the interim traditional
theatre will take an intermission
[Music]
we may just be pressing a pause button
for a short period the rehearsals are
still taking place even though the Opera
season has been postponed until 2021
during this interlude the soprano solos
won't be silenced instead the audience
will experience the virtuosos from their
virtual world there's no question that
the emotions that opera brings out in in
humans will be lost
somewhat online the most important thing
in producing online will be the sound
quality opera obviously is all about the
voice and it's all about music so making
sure that the sound quality of anything
we put out online is the top level we
can produce out
I'm looking forward to the future when
we can have human connections again
because it will be the cultural sector
that restores everybody back to some
sort of normality some sort of emotional
high that we all get when we go to the
theater and you're right we will not get
all of that in the living rooms of one's
home
Toronto's were allowing Xandra theater
was closed during the Spanish flu in
1918 it eventually reopened a hundred
years later it's the same refrain kovat
19 will keep theatres shuttered until
2021 when it's hoped players and patrons
will come back from being away theater
has gone on for over 2,500 years there
have been plagues there have been
viruses that have been pandemics and
it's always come back I have to believe
that it will come back again so Korea
suspended its run a Phantom of the Opera
in March when a Canadian cast member
tested positive for kovin 19 three weeks
later the cast was back on stage but
theater goers have to wear masks and
there are sanitisation stops from the
door to the auditorium Canadian theater
is taking its cues from that part of the
world Theater is essentially a communal
experience otherwise we can all sit at
home which we're doing now and watch
things on screens but that's not the
same thing what happens in a theater and
what's magic about it is the energy
between the audience and the performers
and the end the energy between audience
members
[Music]
Selena Kennedy knows all about that she
thrives on the stage and waits for its
return so I think hopefully this is
gonna make us all much more
compassionate and the kind of stories
that are gonna come out of this time I
think are gonna be very exciting
up next costly creatures we need to make
sure that we're not just leaving those
animals without support
what zoos are doing to keep the doors
open and the residents happy
[Music]
as the pandemic evolves we humans are
not the only creatures facing a new
reality zoos and aquariums across the
world have gone quiet human visitors are
no longer allowed the animals though
still need to be fed and cared for and
since ticket sales stopped so has the
flow of money to pay the bills zoos are
under intense pressure to adapt or go
the way of the dodo
Tom Hayes explores some of their
survival tactics it's a trip to the zoo
like never before and the excitement's
building I wanna see the Lions the Bison
the grizzly bears I love that would be
baby longlegs born just over a week ago
at the Toronto Zoo normally she would be
a big attraction here with 1.2 million
visitors every year but this year is
different
Payton Jackson and the rest of the
family in the car to take in the Toronto
Zoo
Drive Thru they came forward with the
plan that allows people to stay in their
vehicles stage in the parking lot
literally drive through our front
entrance and use a combination of our
walking paths as well as our zoo mobile
route to get a behind-the-scenes unique
experience
[Music]
that unique experience will generate
revenue but not even close to the 51
million dollar annual operating cost
it's not really happening attractions
across the country are facing a real
challenge to keep their creatures fed
and doors open it's honestly it's like
comparable to a death a death of a dream
a death of you know a passion
cherrybrook zoo and st. John's new
brunswick closed for good because of
cove at 19 the Vancouver Aquarium in
Stanley Park is losing 3 million dollars
a month
the hope is to open sometime in June
with limited tickets but planning is
also underway for a worst-case scenario
given that we put aside money to make
sure that we can read home the animals
if we need to close we need to make sure
that we're not you know just leaving
those animals without support and
finding new homes for them it's going to
be a top priority for us then that also
costs money what would be most critical
for them to feel comfortable coming back
to us for a safe experience the Calgary
Zoo has reopened to a limited amount of
visitors but it's star attractions the
giant pandas are on their way home the
zoo can't get enough bamboo to feed the
Bears during the pandemic so they will
head back to China with no public
viewings before they leave just outside
Montreal it takes about 30 pounds of
meat every day to feed the Tigers at
Granby Zoo half a million dollars a year
to feed all 1500 animals with no opening
date in sight the money's running out we
couldn't expect to be able to run on the
two month three months maybe basis and
after that it will be really tough we'll
probably need the bank help and people's
like the foundation to be helping us or
not the government level also some
program the food budget is also an issue
here at the Toronto Zoo it costs over a
million dollars a year to feed the
animals that million dollars usually
comes from parking revenue from a
parking lot
that normally doesn't look like this
with no paying guests for the past eight
weeks many attractions have reached out
online it's a different way to tour the
zoo but the hope is that the drive-thru
concept will still allow for social
distancing and allow families and escape
from the covert lockdown just the
ability to get them out of the house and
to do something as a family and
obviously to support the zoo and all the
employees that have moved working
throughout to take care of the animals
we're happy to come out and see what
it's all about today Jackson and Payton
give the zoo drive-thru a thumbs up
finally getting to enjoy the animals and
it sounds like the feeling was mutual
I think they were happy to see us
coming up so I'm gonna hug my name is
Sharon happy birthday share the Montreal
man building a new and safe way to hug
[Music]
human contact is one of the biggest
missing pieces in our new reality
especially for people trapped in
long-term care homes or elderly people
living at home we've had to find all
kinds of ways to reach out and some
people have taken it to the next level
Alex Montague a know built this hugging
station in front of his Montreal home
his mom he said kept asking for a hug
and so he got creative I think it's a
way for us to understand the importance
how were connected together but I also
think that having the physical act of
touching and their human being is
extremely important to us but you know
what better safe than sorry
he hadn't hugged his elderly parents in
eight months they were in Mexico before
the pandemic hit and been in
self-isolation so this was a pretty
fantastic way to finally safely embrace
and that is our program this week i'm
dona freezin we leave you with more
pictures from the drive-thru zoo would
you like giraffes with that thanks for
watching take care of each other
[Music]